[Música]
hay un recurso una capacidad quizás una
función que es vital que es
extremadamente valiosa para todos los
seres humanos y que nos diferencia de
cualquier animal o de otro ser vivo y es
nuestra disposición creativa
mi trabajo profesional de años ha hecho
que me tenga que asomar o bucear o
descubrir la posibilidad de la fuente de
esta disposición creativa la fuente que
genera que ópera que orienta esta
disposición creativa y que es de
exclusiva producción y consumo humano no
se confunda con ninguna sustancia que
produzca efectos especiales no estoy
hablando de eso esta fuente es la y más
y nación la imaginación es la única que
puede proyectar nuestro pensamiento
hacia una actitud productiva creativa y
dónde está la imaginación afuera adentro
la imaginación la tenemos desde que
nacemos hasta que merecemos
hasta que morimos el tema está en cómo
hacemos para desarrollarla
es absolutamente vital pero la podemos
ubicar en algún lugar del cuerpo
durante siglos por intereses que no
vienen al caso de filósofos de
científicos de estudiosos fue ubicada la
imaginación en distintos lugares de
nuestro envase corporal en una época
fóbica de la imaginación en el corazón
otras veces fue ubicada en el alma y
recientemente las neurociencias y la
neurobiología la ubica en lo profundo de
nuestro cerebro
pero cuál es la función de la
imaginación la función de la imaginación
tiene que ver con promocionar el impulso
de ideas e ideales de búsqueda de eso
que más nos interesa
y como lo hace bueno rápidamente si no
sería muy denso se produce en movimiento
tipo a tr a todo ritmo en un ciclo
vertiginoso en el cerebro y que tiene
que ver con que en algún momento se nos
representa se nos vuelve a presentar
imágenes
que integradas juntas o combinadas
pueden componer una realidad son
imágenes reales que pueden hacer que
nosotros construyamos una realidad ajena
a nuestros cinco sentidos y que no se va
a dar a la acción en este encuentro pero
puede ser posible entonces un concepto
tu pregunta difícil la imaginación es
una realidad fuera de la realidad no es
más que lo que acabamos de plantear
ahora bien estas imágenes que se nos
representan y que tienen que ver con
nuestra cultura con nuestra familia con
nuestros juegos con nuestra educación
aprendimos el lenguaje imaginando y
tampoco es patrimonio a la imaginación
del mundo artístico ni del arte es
patrimonio de todos nosotros si nosotros
no imaginamos de quién son las ideas los
proyectos y los ideales que estamos
realizando a diario
vamos a buscar un ejemplo
para que ustedes vean que la imaginación
tiene un ejercicio concreto y rafaelino
en rafael la calle
qué
trae a la memoria y respecto de una
docente que es olga cossettini que ella
con su hermana habían implementado
habían experimentado y habían puesto en
marcha una escuela que era la escuela
activa la escuela serena
con gran desarrollo de la imaginación y
para que ustedes vean y vamos a pasar
del discurso a la acción
[Música]
dijeron bueno vamos a hacer un coro
imagínense ustedes que nosotros con
ustedes ahora y aquí armamos un cordón
pero no se decantan no tengo oído nunca
cante de casualidad que hablo
no todos vamos a estar incluidos en un
coro que partitura usamos para hacer un
coro conjunto de gente que canta
vamos a hacer un coro de pájaros
brillantes es decir cada una imita el
pájaro que se le ocurre chingolo
gorriones paraguayito golondrina lo que
se le ocurre
y todos comenzaron a imitar un pájaro
que por supuesto como la vida misma
todos los días ese coro era distinto y
llegó a tener seis mil integrantes en
sus registros entre alumnos y exalumnos
pero con una singularidad
había dos alumnos que imitaban al
paraguay hito el mismo pájaro pero le
dijieron a la maestra nosotros vamos a
invitar un mismo pájaro pero él va a
imitar un paraguas y está cantando en
libertad y yo un paraguas y está
cantando en prisión
[Música]
maravilloso la imaginación y que trae a
colación que la imaginación está
impregnada de nuestros propios valores y
que en este caso la imaginación creó un
espacio y un espacio que involucra que
incluye en la diversidad
podríamos entrenar la imaginación pero
tampoco hace cambios del mundo pero hay
algunas pound hacen que nosotros podamos
tener presente al momento de querer
imaginar lo primero una motivación
es fundamental tener una motivación algo
obsesivo una búsqueda lo que más nos
importa en la vida lo que deseamos y
queremos realizar o queremos ser
una motivación y luego una intuición que
es una suerte de olfato de un depósito
de nuestra experiencia que hace que
tengamos confianza en lo que sabemos
hasta el momento por la vida y así
podamos fundamentar esta motivación
motivación e intuición
[Música]
y otro criterio importante que
movilizaría inmoviliza la imaginación es
la libertad
[Música]
la libertad de que la libertad de pensar
alguna vez por fuera de lo sistemático
secuencial estructurado lógico y
razonable
salir de los cinco sentidos y
permitirnos que la motivación de la
intuición nos haga pensar en libertad
con esta pregunta qué pasaría si hago o
realizó tal cosa
ya está el último criterio el tiempo no
va tengo tiempo para nada mira señal del
tiempo para imaginar obviamente que
alguien está imaginando por nosotros
pero el tiempo es un tiempo de reflexión
cuando nos bañamos cuando nos levantamos
cuando nos acostábamos cuando aprendemos
el fuego para el hallado son segundos de
reflexión en donde se nos puede venir a
la cabeza esa suerte de combinación
constructiva que tiene que ver con
elementos de la imaginación elementos
reales
si no fueran reales es una fantasía
la diferencia entre fantasía e
imaginación es que la fantasía mezcla y
combina elementos que no pueden pasar a
acción que no pueden ser realidad la
imaginación necesita inevitablemente que
se convierta en acción
se animan a imaginar
vamos a hacer un pequeño ejercicio no
tienen que invertir dinero no
necesitamos sponsor combustible relajado
y valor del dólar ni nada por el estilo
solamente un pequeño movimiento muy
despacito no se desgarren no hacemos
ejercicios precompetitivos
hacia la derecha van a mover por favor
voluntariamente y así lo decían giren a
la derecha si están de acuerdo con la
todavía no pero ustedes son facilísimo
este es un problema cuando nos
adelantamos las consignas
por favor giren a la derecha el cuello y
la cabeza si están de acuerdo con la
afirmación que voy a realizar hay mucha
gente que está de acuerdo yo no hice
ninguna afirmación pago
y por favor giren a la izquierda la
cabeza suavemente si no están de acuerdo
con la afirmación que voy a realizar
se entendió la consigna no hace falta
que le reiteré bien
ahí va la afirmación la derecha lo que
están de acuerdo si a la izquierda los
que no están de acuerdo
mil ratones se rebelan
el gato y la gata tienen miedo
ah bueno
espectacular esto no admite registro
alguno en el mundo
ustedes han dado una muestra de
imaginación colectiva una muestra de
imaginación comunitaria muchos de
ustedes lo saben porque movieron la
cabeza pero inevitablemente hay una
representación simbólica de lo que es el
gato y lo que es el ratón y qué dos
gatos con poderes y con una naturaleza
que nos han enseñado desde chico pueden
más que mil ratones y los que han girado
a la izquierda piensan que no hacen
falta pocos y de mucho poder sino más
pequeños más hábiles y que generen miedo
es una conjetura que yo hago pero es el
imaginario social es el imaginario
colectivo y así se define y se crea lo
que es democracia paz violencia en el
imaginario colectivo
[Música]
la imaginación no da felicidad
pero la permite
la imaginación no se acopla a esta
realidad permite saltear la
[Música]
si no imaginamos creativamente estamos
condenados a que a vivir el presente
exclusivamente y fundamentalmente la
idea es que la imaginación siempre
necesita para ser útil y ser tal
de un tiempo de acción
gracias por imaginar conmigo
[Aplausos]
[Música]